we're going to begin this hour with a
new call for transparency and
accountability at social media platforms
from a former Tech Insider Francis
Haugen her new book is called The Power
of One it tells the story of how she
blew the whistle on Facebook you'll
recall that story back in 2021 she was a
Facebook data scientist and she well she
resigned from that position then
anonymously leaked thousands of pages of
research from the company now known as
meta of course that leak exposed to
potentially negative effect of
Facebook's algorithms and she later
revealed her identity on 60 Minutes here
is some of what she had to say to our
colleagues there
one of the consequences of how Facebook
is picking out that content today is it
is optimizing for Content that gets
a reaction but its own research is
showing that content that is hateful
that is divisive that is polarizing
it's easier to inspire people to anger
than it is to other emotions
Hogan's book is released at the same
moment as the Surgeon General is warning
about the mental health effects of
social media on young people we should
point out before we get to the
conversation we did reach out to Matt
about the book also the surgeon
general's advisory but meta has declined
the comments so with no further Ado
Francis housing good morning thank you
for being here thank you for inviting me
the book is powerful it's eye-opening
and you say it's not about fear or
despair it's about each reader with each
page they turn being on a path to a
brighter future for social media
what do you think the biggest issue is
right now in the way of that future um
media is the powerful industry in the
world for how opaque it is you know it's
like having a soda company where people
keep compulsively consuming it and when
scientists say we want to research this
the company comes back and says no we'll
sue you that literally is what Facebook
does they've sued researchers who caught
them what they on their face
companies that are opaque can cut
Corners at the public expense and
there's no consequences until someone
like you comes along right so like with
Google results you can analyze them
things probably facing with food you can
say what's in the product but with this
you don't really know what's in the
product because you don't know how it's
being served up now meta would say and
they have launched 30 different I think
items to help parents in particular
protect their kids in various ways is it
enough what's fascinating about that
list I asked about it backstage a number
of those features launched the summer
before I came out because the UK passed
a law saying that kids privacy had to be
protected and yet Facebook is claiming
this is how we're responding to Francis
so I would say no it's not enough
because it was already in the works
before you blew away well it's it's also
you know those features we don't have
any accountability on them like
researchers don't get to study the
effectiveness Facebook just gets to use
them as PR marketing Stones that's a
great Point why have regulations and you
know these efforts been easier in places
like Europe than here in the US I think
a big part of it is we take for granted
that the English version of Facebook the
version of Facebook in the United States
is actually the cleanest safest version
of Facebook in the world and so in
Europe they speak many more languages
and many of those languages got very
very little investment for safety
interventions and so they were paying a
much higher cost for using social media
than we were and so they were more
willing to act
you say that this wasn't the book that
you expected to write
um and it details your path of becoming
a whistleblower why did you title it the
power of one
and you know the original book I set out
to write was uh focused on the idea that
people have a lot of reasons why they
don't follow their hearts you know that
they they're afraid of losing their jobs
of losing whatever be impoverished
losing their homes losing their spouses
you know they're going to end up
estranged from everything falling out of
complacency and and I had all those
experiences in my late 20s at the same
time
and I came back from it
and I wanted to write a story about
um that where do we find our strength
like how do we stand up when we fall
down because the hardest thing I did
wasn't blow the whistle on Facebook but
because I lived those experiences I was
able to follow my heart and stand up in
the truth Francis it's such a great
point about access to the underlying
data so researchers and independent fact
checkers can look at what Facebook and
other social media platforms are doing
meta I should say but they would also
say look these algorithms these are like
our secret recipes these are the things
that make us profitable companies bottom
line business yeah how do you balance
how do you balance the two I mean the
Public's right to know if they have such
a right in this case and the company's
right to be a competitive business so
there's a lot of different ways we can
release data imagine something as simple
as how many children are online at 10 11
midnight one two three four A.M
something as simple as that is not the
secret sauce of Facebook but if they had
to publish those numbers every week I
guarantee you parents groups who stand
up and demand action you get Advertiser
boycotts you get divestment you might
even get laws saying if you can't drive
these numbers down you know that's
you're in trouble that gives freedom to
the companies to innovate to find the
right ways to give kids more control
over their usage but holds them
accountable you know that makes perfect
sense because as a father I don't have
the secrets to the recipe what I have is
noise in rooms when I'm walking through
hallways and as I Creek open the door I
see a lit light underneath covers and it
might be 10 or 11 p.m and I'm saying
wait a minute I thought you were
supposed to be in bed hours ago
um but how do we hold these companies
accountable you know we have parents at
home that are watching this and they're
saying to themselves I'm doing my best
as a parent but also have a job I can't
monitor every moment I can do what I can
through these apps to monitor what
they're doing on their phones but it is
ultimately up to these companies because
they know what they're doing how do we
hold them accountable we need to call
our elected representatives there are
laws pending right now things like the
platform accountability and transparency
act that do things like give Safe Harbor
to researchers demand data access these
things allow us Advanced research but
for kids specifically you know we
haven't updated our privacy laws for
kids online since the 90s like think
about how much the internet has changed
since then wow and I want to I want to
address one thing you can do a lot as a
parent but these companies have hundreds
of employees that are trying to make
their apps stickier yeah you know you're
fighting an impossible fight and parents
are on these apps too yeah and parents
that's scary to hear you are you are
fighting an impossible fight it's uh
it's the afternoon after school hours in
Tel Aviv where my teenager uh is a
rising ninth grader uh and I've already
got three calls this morning on my phone
I guarantee it's not to say Dad I love
you it's to say Dad remove the time
limits off of Instagram
I there's always a reason there's always
a reason why the time limits need to be
released you show us uh what's it what's
at stake here we do just deserve a
better and brighter future for social
media Francis Haugen thank you very much
congratulations on the book Thank you
that book is the power of Juan it is
available now wherever you get your
books